I was fortunate enough to get invited to
the wrap party that you guys had and you
know fast and you had just finished
pretty much finishing up the whole
series and they asked would I come and
and sort of host an evening and I'm such
a big fan of the coma I loved I loved
doing it and I'd never been to Belfast
before and that was a lovely City and so
I had a fantastic evening but I have to
say I got to know you very well that
night yeah you gave this speech that was
really from the heart about what the
show meant to you and what it meant to
you as someone who had grown up with
some insecurities and and and how
important it was for you to let fans and
everyone know that you were growing up
that way and you had had this success
and you wanted to pass it on to others
and and share that to them you gave this
speech and I thought this is such a
lovely man he's such a you're such a
nice guy you really are just I mean it
was kind of it was it was a purely
emotional thing I didn't really think
about saying it before I went out there
and I kind of can't remember it all but
but the kind of gist of it was that yeah
as somebody who grew up overweight and
kind of unhappy because of it I'm
thinking that that you know life was
gonna pass you by because of it and all
the times where you just kind of go to
bed and you wake up you got to bed
anything I'd give anything to wake up
and not have this way and then suddenly
all the time that you're thinking that
especially you're getting when I was in
kind of 1922 think while I was feeling
that about myself David and Dan our
producers and everybody else connected
with the show they were looking for me
mm-hmm they were looking for exactly me
and not and it's not just a case of
they're going to accept well what I
consider to be faults about myself but
they're going to see them as virtues and
they're going to be my key into this
amazing
experience and meet on meeting all these
amazing people and if I'd have known
that they were looking for me and what
kind of effect that was gonna have on
the rest of my life then I'd have then I
just want to be able to believe it
that's a shortened version of this beta
gram I rambled on and you didn't that
ramble it was beautiful and it was just
as beautiful as that you just said right
now is really lovely really a lovely
thing and important if people hear that
yeah gladden young people out there near
do you hear that I hope so